do you mind if i go out for a drink with
these guys
uh no come on let's get out of here go
home
okay um i'm gonna be a few minutes so
it's only
20 past five i still have to do my faxes
you know what you should uh you should
come with us
because we're you know we're all going
out and it could be a good chance for
you to
see what people are like outside of the
office you know i i think it could be
fun no it sounds sounds good oh no
seriously we gotta get going yeah yeah
yeah
um
what's in the uh what's in the bag
still have to talk to him no definitely
all right dude awesome
will do
do i think
i'll be invited to the wedding
what's going on what is going on you
guys are playing like a bunch of girls
you know what let me take roy all right
switching
up a notch come on
[Applause]
shoot it shoot it
whoa whoa whoa whoa foul naked
aggression
oh that is
you're right jim suck it up
he's afraid of me now
oh how much does it hurt how much does
it hurt
[Applause]
what the hell man
take it easy no you take it easy
come on i talked to this cow it looks
good mm-hmm i haven't signed anything
hey baby hey
look at larry bird
larry legend
yeah he's uh he's pretty good huh
oh yeah let's get you into a tub
yeah let's give you a little time
some might even say we had our first
date last night
oh really really why might some say that
because it was dinner
by candlelight
dinner and a show if you include
michael's movie
and there was dancing and fireworks
pretty good date we didn't dance
you're right we didn't dance it was more
like
swaying
but still romantic
swaying isn't dancing
please i didn't leave you at a high
school hockey game
i have some taxes to get out
oh come on pam i
okay we didn't dance
and i was totally joking anyway i mean
it's not really a date if the girl goes
home to her fiance
albert
hey uh i uh you know heard there's a
rumor going around about you know you
used to have a crush on pam oh no no no
no it's it's cool cause i know you're a
good guy and i know that that crush
ended a long time ago so yeah
we're cool
right yeah nope yeah definitely you know
i'm it's great with me because wait
glad she has a friend at work she can
get through the day with oh she's done
all that bad bad you know when she gets
home yeah i like talking to her too so
uh
we're cool right yes
yeah all right yep all right cool man
sweet
dreams are just that
their dreams they help get you through
the day
like the thing about the terrace it's
nice
but um
i don't know it's just something i read
in this book when i was 12.
the girl in the book has a terrace
outside of her bedroom and she planted
flowers on it and i just loved that
just always kind of stuck with me
so you're not doing it
how did you know
why not
just like no big reason just a bunch of
little reasons
come on
roy's right there's no guarantee it's
going to lead to anything anyway
roy said that
what you have something you want to say
you got to take a chance on something
sometime pam
i mean do you want to be a receptionist
here always
oh excuse me i'm fine with my choices
are
yeah
it's impractical i'm not gonna
try to get a house like that
um they don't even make houses like that
in scranton
so i'm never gonna
what
i want us to make it
i want a fresh start that's awesome
that's what i want
okay but
in order for us to make it there can't
be any secrets between us
i didn't do anything i
asked anybody i totally could have and i
didn't at all just listen
remember that casino night about a month
before we were supposed to get married
i kissed jim
what
he told me how he felt and i guess i had
feelings too and we kissed jim came on
to you just listen no i am listening
that's the problem i'm listening don't
yell
don't yell
this is over
yeah you're right this is so over
you kidding me pam
come on
they're gonna call the cops
no i paid them off
jet ski money
all of it
i'm gonna kill jim halpert
so do you want to see it or not i don't
know they're like friday night crowds
oh my god you're like agoraphobic
agoraphobic yeah really yeah you would
rather sit on your couch and watch a
philly's game than go out to a movie
with your awesome girlfriend absolutely
correct later gem kev have a good
weekend yeah
bye okay so this is what's gonna happen
you're gonna suck it up here we go and
we're gonna go to dinner okay and then
we're gonna go to the movies
hey help her
hey
pam please call security
every day for eight years i have brought
pepper spray into this office to protect
myself and my fellow employees and every
day for eight years people have laughed
at me
well
who's laughing now
sorry i almost got you killed
yeah
that was nuts
he could have broken your nose or
something
crazy
it's just so stupid
i mean getting back with roy and
everything
i mean what was i thinking right
no i mean you guys really seem to have a
strong connection
not anymore
it's um
it's completely over now
we'll see
i'm sure you guys will
find your way back to one another
someday
jim
i am really sorry oh yeah don't worry
about it
[Music]
what's up roy hey man
relax man i'm not gonna
hit you oh
[Music]
you good i'm good how you doing i'm good
hey daryl what's happening
what's up guys
what's going on with pam oh she's good
actually yeah she's uh
she's in new york she's at art school
really yeah she's doing really well
she's engaged
um
[Music]
to me
congrats man ah thanks man
appreciate that
so pam's happy
yeah i'd say she's happy i mean she
loves her classes
loves the city
and last night she was out with her
friends till like
8 a.m wow
what
you were a friend
you